so finding the forest through the trees
actually became the name of the system
that I'm going to
neway that has just been published 2 to
build very very large buildings about a
year in a bit ago we were we proposed
and received a grant funding to
basically set out with some engineers
some cost consultants some code
consultants to build what now is a 240
page document that really lays out the
plans of how to build very large
buildings up to 30 stories tall and
would using this new system we designed
it very specifically around Vancouver
and we decided that our report needed to
demonstrate that this was a rigorous
from a technical point of view but also
rigorous enough to show that it was
cost-effective and tell the story why
consumers would want to buy it why
developers won't want to do it how
people would ultimately market these
ideas and also obviously the other sort
of critical parts of how they worked and
what their sustainable story really
would be see in Vancouver where I live
it's high earthquake zone we want to
really challenge our system by building
the highest earthquake zone in Canada by
proposing it in that environment and
also proposing it in a dense urban
environment and really work with
contractors to understand how we would
actually technically build something on
that scale so the system's actually
remarkably simple the first version of
this I built with my son when he was six
and we sat down on the ground together
and put it together sometimes the best
ideas are just that easy and I sort of
pulled I work with some outstanding
world class would engineers at Vancouver
i'm lucky i come from a wood culture and
there's some outstanding would engineers
I've worked with the engineers of this
building in New York and and my
engineers in Vancouver actually have
been helping the New York firm
understand would a little more we we
have a great culture for wood and when I
pulled them aside I said guys you know
my son Macklin I've been making this and
I'm really think this is interesting and
this has some real potential build big
and what do you guys think and they sort
of said yeah this actually works and we
started working on it more and more over
the last five years until we reach this
point where we realized that it's not
only possible it's actually really
practical to do this and it's shaking
things up a little bit in a big
conversation worldwide because this just
came out two weeks ago publicly it's
an interesting moment for me just
personally for our firm because what's
happened is you know we spoke to CNN a
week ago and we're talking to Bulgaria
newspapers and some guy from Iraq
constant you know contacted me about how
to do this so it's become a very quick
and very instant conversation because it
seems so different the idea you know to
get to nine stories is astounding to
talk about 30 stories obviously is a
very new paradigm shift for the world to
get their head around and and ultimately
we think it's very realistic much like
what Andrew just described the idea is
motivated by sustainable methods of
building these big urban buildings but
also it's about how we innovate for
faster lighter less expensive and better
performing for the global scales of
challenges and not those challenges
again climate change world housing we've
got to deal with them because as we talk
world housing especially in the
developing world the issues kind of
collide if we build the way we're
building today to solve that three
billion people that need a new
affordable home in the next 20 years we
are obviously going to significantly
impact climate footprint and we can't do
that there has to be a new way so the
the system as I say it's really simple
and in our case we use a little bit of
steel it's effectively a ninety-eight
percent wood building the elevator like
Andrews building the elevator cores the
stair cores are all wood these using
these mass timber products but we use a
little bit of steel and the reason we do
that is in a high earthquake zone we
need something that's ductile that gives
a little and gives it sort of has a
little more elasticity to it and so we
use the steel ironically as the weak
joint in the design so for anybody in
engineering this is a strong column week
beam design and what's interesting in
the way we approach it is we had some of
the best seismic engineers in North
America do our peer review and what
what's interesting is the formula
technical way that an engineer now
analyzes our building is it uses the
exact same software you would in
concrete so it's actually very easy for
a lot of engineers to get their heads
into how to do this it's just using this
very new material the material is mass
timber materials that Andrew touched on
laminated strand lumber laminated veneer
lumber and CLT cross laminated
timber have been around for a long time
100 years ago and bc if you wanted to
build a fireproof wall you took two by
fours and nailed them together a two by
sixes and nailed them together and made
a massive solid wall so when I renovate
a building in my community i'm often
hitting a massive piece of wood and the
only reason it's there is because of
fire is completely hidden in the wall
but what we know is massive massive
pieces of wood actually resist fire and
behaved really predictably in fire which
is very counterintuitive to the way a
lot of people feel about would but the
difference is it's easy to light a fire
with a little piece of little sticks to
start it up it's very hard if you start
with a log and try to catch it on fire
it's very difficult to get into work
that's why the torches on the balcony
weren't weren't lighting up necessarily
for for when they were putting the
waterproofing on so just to kind of give
you an overview I'm not going to go into
a lot of the detail of our report but
what we were trying to do again is say
it's one thing to have a good
sustainable message but what we know
statistically is ninety-five percent of
the public will tell you that they will
pay more for something that is green but
only five percent actually do this
system these ideas don't sell because
they're good for the planet that's not
what's going to happen even though
luckily Andrews building sold out with
people with that attitude that's not
going to propagate the idea so instead
we had to make this cost effective when
part of it with speed and part of it was
showing that it had all the same
flexibility as any concrete building so
this is a concrete building and what we
did in our study is we actually looked
at a 12-story concrete building 20 story
concrete building a 30-story concrete
building in every step of the way
because concrete's what we build with in
Vancouver not steal every step of the
way we would compare our wood system to
a concrete system no matter what the
what the metrics were going to be we
would get a rigorous comparison and what
came really important in that was that
in order to get developers to want to do
these kinds of buildings they want
flexibility and we wanted to prove that
we could do this not just in residential
buildings but ultimately in office
buildings and in order to do that you
really want a plan a building plan
that's call it that's that's wall free
it's just open free plan
so that means in an office you can lay
out your office space however you want
and you can build if it was residential
you can build your residential unit
wherever you want so in our system we're
using these large-scale panels and we
tilt them up and they're 64 feet long if
they're LVL or L&SL so there's six
stories tall when you've tip them up and
we're building up to 12 stories we're
building with glulam columns just like
these big beams here slabs of these
large mass timber panels a central core
and an elevator core made entirely of
the timber panels and some steel
Ledger's that help us again with the
flexibility of the system what we found
is up to 20 stories up to 12 we have
this free beautiful free open plan you
could have all glass exterior which a
lot of buildings are made that way
that's not the way hopefully we'll be
building buildings in the future because
it's obviously terrible from an energy
performance point of view but you know
this gives the developers flexibility
and what we found is if we move away
from the columns and put solid panels on
the exterior we can actually get up to
20 stories or we could put brace walls
inside a little bit more like Andrews
building with a few more load-bearing
walls on the inside and ultimately to
get to 30 stories we'd mix those two
things make a fairly solid exterior and
walls on the inside since this diagram
is made we've actually been able to show
that we can do option 2 and 3 here all
the way to 30 stories which means that
we can make an office building 30
stories tall wood means we can make a
flexible plan for a developer to do a
housing project in 30 stories which is
an extraordinary sort of result that we
were truthfully a bit surprised by as we
push the engineering further and further
so I'm going to go quickly now in this
part but as I said what was important
about our system was that we tested
everything so the in this case we
actually met with construction companies
some of the biggest ones in Canada and
talked about how you would actually
erect them and for us what was funny
with that is that they didn't know who
to bring to the meetings then this isn't
something anybody does do we bring wood
carpenters no because these panels are
massive this isn't wood carpentry
we know we bring concrete guys know
because that doesn't make any sense
there really isn't a clear trade that
actually builds this it's probably
closest to steal in some respects
because it's kind of a kit of parts that
goes together but it's in many respects
kind of this big unknown as nobody's
been doing it but they were excited
about it not was what was great it's
every single group we talked to from
contractors to developers to building
code officials were really a intrigued
and be Oh after they learned and read
more and understood what we were talking
about really all of the obstacles seem
to be slowly disappearing for us
everybody was coming on side because the
ideas seemed to be researched understood
well enough and with the contractors to
our surprise we basically are building
up the central elevator core bracing it
and building in lifts of six stories at
a time so you can see these panels the
elegance is basically the simple way for
everybody to think about it is a
two-by-four the way we build small
residential houses has now become a
giant piece of wood that's 8 feet wide
and 64 feet long and three and a half
inches thick and at times seven inches
thick to allow us to get these huge
Heights